new york the home of wall street
the home of the largest and most
prestigious stock market in the world
in the early days of the outbreak the
large wall street companies wanted to
ensure their assets remained protected
they could see the situation quickly
escalating and predicted that the
government wasn't going to be able to
keep the peace for long
so they brought in some outside help to
defend their various corporate interests
and this is where we're introduced
to the last man battalion
[Music]
from the first time i put on a uniform
i knew i was on the path to become the
man i was destined to be
i knew i had accepted a burden that was
going to last a lifetime
and even when i left our country's
military behind my obligation for
service remained that obligation is one
i and all the men and women of the last
man battalion take seriously
we will get the job done we will serve
with honor and dignity and we will if
necessary fight to the very last man
because that is who we are and what we
do the last man battalion security you
can count on
the last man battalion or lmb are a
private military company made up of u.s
military veterans who were brought on
board by their leader charles bliss who
himself was a former us army officer
charles bliss was a former united states
army's first special forces operational
detachment
delta force
he was proud of the uniform and knew
from the moment that he first put it on
that he would continue to serve long
after he left the military behind
bliss leads with an iron fist
duty honor and peace through strength
were his guiding principles
he holds a deep love and respect for his
troops
both in the army and the lmb this in
turn inspires fierce loyalty from the
troops under his command
after bliss retired from the armed
forces he decided to work in the private
security sector
and this is where he first created the
last man battalion
in the early days of the outbreak bliss
was contacted by an associate about the
situation in new york
hi rick it's charles
i got your message regarding the
situation in new york and i think you're
absolutely right
things are going to get out of hand
faster than the government realizes
they're going to lose control before
they've even signed the deployment
orders
you ask me the only thing that's going
to work is to impose absolute authority
on the population
people are scared and angry and that's
when they'll act stupid and risk the
lives of others i've seen it too many
times now you want to shut those
instincts down and enforce zero
tolerance
anything beyond that is not going to
produce results
and in the long run
that will cost you a lot more than
hiring my people
bliss went to work placing a proposal on
the type of security detail he could
offer one of the larger financial
businesses in the area
hey charles this is nancy again i've
reviewed your mission proposal and i
think it looks solid i believe the board
of directors will have no problem
approving it
the only thing that stands out perhaps
is the lack of support on wall street
but i think we all understand that under
the circumstances it's best to
prioritize our primary assets in midtown
i'm sure our foreign investors will be
delighted to hear that you're taking
them into account as well anyway the
board will be reviewing the plan in two
hours or so just thought i'd send you
heads up talk to you soon
the goal was to protect the buildings
and their physical assets by any means
necessary
until the situation had been resolved
and the city was back to normal
as the crisis worsened
many of the companies left the city
but the lmb remained and continued to
protect the sights
but as time went by blissiness forces
saw the city go from bad to worse
he was growing tired of standing by and
watch the city fall into complete chaos
the indecisive local authorities and the
government's complete lack of ability to
control the situation was only becoming
more clear as the days passed
by the time that the general public
realized that this was more than just a
bad flu outbreak
bliss had already come to the conclusion
that there was no point in handing over
his men's lives in order to protect some
physical assets
because at the rate things were going
there would be no one coming back to use
them anyway
after the jtf withdrew from the city
bliss decided that it was up to the lmb
to restore order to new york
what we need to do is assess our
resources and define our mission
statement
the statement is clear
we must retake control and with the
resources we have left it's also clear
we can't afford any half measures
every soldier counts
every soldier is a critical resource
there are no reinforcements being
deployed there is no air support
we work slow and steady we secure the
city sector by sector and then we hold
them for dear life i need you all to be
in your feet ready to make some quick
decisions
it's better to shoot someone innocent
than to let someone guilty get away and
it's better to shoot first than to risk
being shot even if you're not 100 sure
that's how we will win this war
that's how we will save this city
collateral damage is to be expected
although bliss was a man of his word and
that breaking contracts was generally
not in his nature
he dumped his wall street clients
knowing full well that their motivation
was pure self-interest
he saw no greater good and risking his
men's lives to guard the dead server
farms of large financial organizations
charles listen
this is a breach of contract you are
hired to secure our assets as agreed
upon and you've left them vulnerable
we're talking billions in damages here
i don't give a damn about your assets
nancy not anymore
we followed our contract to the letter
and in return you stuck my men in here
under government-issued quarantine
expected to protect empty buildings in a
dying city
well i can't ask him to do that
we've got bigger fish to fry you're not
going to get away with this charles
what are you going to do
sumi
you and your family are going to die you
will all die if i don't do something
here something more important than
keeping watch over a dead server farm
oh
and see someone about that cough
it sounds nasty
bliss went on to disobey direct orders
from local jtf
this action had bliss and his entire
company labeled as mutineers and enemies
of the government
convinced that not just new york but the
whole country will collapse under the
spread of the virus
bliss tells his people that the lmb will
use any and all means necessary to make
sure that they
and the city survived
that only a strong hand could salvage
and restore what was left
with the financial backing now gone
bliss would now have to assess the
available resources and plan every step
of the way
l b were running the area demanding
absolute control with zero tolerance for
disobedience or differing point of view
any dissent or even questioning of the
lmb operations would result in instant
retaliation with even minor incidents
resulting in death at the hands of the
lmb soldiers
in an attempt to keep their numbers
bolstered the l b would often capture
jtf and members of other factions that
they saw as beneficial to their cause
and give them the option of either
joining up
or being killed
with the jtf pushed back to the brink of
collapse it wasn't long before the lmb
were widely known as being the strongest
faction in manhattan
and eventually with this
came the offer of an alliance from
someone who had forever changed the
outcome of this conflict
former first wave agent turned rogue
aaron kina
approached bliss with a proposal that
would benefit both sides
keenan needed the lmb to help establish
dominance in the city and through doing
so the lmb would have access to
cutting-edge shd technology available to
all division agents
who bliss knew would become a problem in
the days to come
[Music]
together keener and bliss launched many
operations against the other factions
the jtf and the division
one of the most notable
being the bombing of a jtf helicopter
that was carrying the division's second
wave commander as well as the majority
of the new york second wave agents
it wasn't until the division pick up an
shd transponder signal that they would
realize the true threat of the lmb
on their way through the new york police
academy building they were met with
heavy l b resistance
once they made it down to the basement
they found the transponder it would
reveal that not only were a number of
first wave agents still alive
but that they had gone rogue and joined
forces with the lmb
but even with the rogue agents in their
ranks the lmb failed to defend the site
from the shd agents
next the jtf intercepted a signal coming
from the russian consulate
inside a russian scientist claims to
have information on the green poison so
the division agents were quickly sent in
to extract him
however kina and the lmb were one step
ahead
while the division agents were tied up
with the lmb rogue agents grab the
scientist and escape in a helicopter
at this point the l b numbers are
starting to suffer through casualties to
the division
the communication hub at queen's tunnel
construction site was next to be taken
down by the division in jtf
and the grand central station which
acted as a strategic forward base also
met an abrupt end at the hands of the
division
the supplies ammunition and manpower
lost at these sites were now starting to
be felt throughout the lmb ranks
as the government forces continue to
push forward the l b eventually fall
back to their main headquarters
the united nations building
it's here alongside kina's rogues that
the l b will make their last stand
however kinah had other plans
he realizes that the lmb are finished
and will be quickly dealt with by the
division
so he evacuates the russian scientist
instructing two of his rogue agents to
stay behind and jam the shd tracking
software allowing them a clean getaway
the jtf and the division launch a huge
attack
the majority of the lmb are killed in
the u.n building as the division agents
sweep through
when bliss hears of kina's betrayal he
is thrown into a state of rage
but before going after him he decided to
deal with the second wave agents
storming the compound
staying true to himself bliss displays
the attributes that he expects from his
men
loyalty and honor
by staying behind and fighting to the
death
rather than simply escaping in his
personal helicopter
the division eventually eliminates the
lmb command and then finds themselves in
direct combat with the leader of the
last man battalion
bliss's helicopter is eventually shot
down by the agents
killing bliss in the process
the remaining lmb personnel evacuated
the building most going into hiding
but it wasn't long before one of bliss's
officers jumped in to continue his work
captain perez has taken position inside
a water treatment plant
where his squad of l b have a fully
functional armored personnel carrier
however it wasn't long before news of
this reached the government
they decided that the best course of
action would be to bomb the plant before
the lmb can take it out onto the streets
but the division disagreed
saying that the loss of the water
treatment plant would only slow down the
progress towards rebuilding the city
so they launched an attack against the
lmb to shut them down before the
government proceeded with destroying the
facility
the agents were successful in stopping
the lmb and taking down the apc along
with captain perez
the splintered pmc scatters
and are no longer a major threat to the
city
it wasn't until the jtf began moving
into the west side piers that the lmb
would be heard from again
through an agreement with the rikers and
cleaners they team up with a common goal
in mind
to hunt down the man who had betrayed
them most of all the lmb
aaron kina
now
the brass says there's a good reason for
us to be working with the others out
here they say they've called a truce
maybe even made an alliance because all
of us have gotten screwed one way or
another but that piece of [ __ ] aaron
keenan
and they say keener's been spotted on
the west side piers
and that's why all of us are moving in
to hunt that little bastard down
although the shared hatred brought them
together
the lmb weren't all happy about the
situation
so imagine us
the lmb
last bastion of combat discipline on
this island professional soldiers from
top to bottom
now imagine us teaming up with the
rikers and the cleaners
because that's exactly what we're doing
we're going to be patrolling together
doing joint ops
everything
and i have got to tell you
i don't like it
one little bit
but man
i just don't get it
we beat those other guys
one group's crazier than a [ __ ] house
rat and the others are mobbed with no
discipline
what the hell do they have to offer us
you ask me it's going to be more work
keeping them in line than we'll get out
of them
if you ask me
it's not worth it
but nobody's asking me
which is typical
several months later the l b have been
pushed back to a mere shadow of their
former selves
after the loss of their commanding
officers most have split up into small
leaderless groups
with a number of others seeking refuge
among the other factions including the
jtf
after the black tusk made themselves
known in washington dc they suffered
massive casualties at the hands of the
shd and their operatives
looking for ways to boost their numbers
while in new york they came across
members of the once powerful faction of
the last man battalion
with their experience in the field
particularly with the division the black
tusk offered them a place within their
ranks
and the opportunity to avenge the death
of their leader
charles bliss
the l b were absorbed into the black
tusk and given a position within the
newly created unit
known as white tusk
the white tusks are an elite division of
the black tusk
they consist of experienced black tusk
soldiers along with the remains of the
last man battalion
there are more lethal more advanced and
experienced unit of their btsu
counterparts
while the lmb is a faction no longer
exists
the remnants of this once powerful group
are now armed with new tech and weaponry
and are a part of a much larger
more established pmc
they have been given a new start and a
new purpose
the eradication of the division
this video was originally intended to be
a small update to the last man battalion
story to bring it up to speed with the
full story as it currently stands in the
division two
but after reviewing my original video
from over three years ago i realized
that it was only my second or third
video on the lore of the game and that
i've probably learned a thing or two
since then and didn't really do this
story justice so i decided to
consolidate it into a full video
i actually noticed a few others that
need an update that i might do the same
thing with if i have the time
anyway i hope you've enjoyed this and
i'll catch in the next one cheers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh